yeah hello I hope this stream is working
all right I still don't have that huge
experience there with the YouTube only
the second stream ever and I hope it
worked with the announcement of the
stream and everything I'm not sure it
does we'll see what happens okay it says
live stream has started I hope it it
works but I'm not quite sure yeah okay I
see it start but I wondered if this
announcement if this worked all right i
mean i had scared you with this for ten
o'clock and it should have popped up in
everybody's in everybody's subscription
feed but i don't see any spectators yet
so this is not pointing towards this
thing working hmm ok let's see if check
is chad is working huh that's weird hmm
yeah she says I've got two spectators
but
mmm it's rather weird and add this
announcement down okay people see it can
hear hear me fine okay a lot hello then
yeah hello to this broadcast I think I'm
trying to see that I get the chat that I
don't have to i need to adjust this a
little bit let's see if i can do it see
if i can it's tough it's tough to set
this up in a way that i can actually see
the chat fine without having to just
stuff you all the time
that's no good okay I'm sorry for the t
you think problems here no it's not
ideal have to find some other setup in
my window yeah so that it works better
so I basically have to tilt my head to
the right side from my enter all the
time no way to avoid it for the moment
okay let's get going with the actual
content of all this um we're going to
look at the penultimate round here of
the Tata Steel tournament and encourage
you all to ask questions about games and
I try to answer them to the best of my
ability and to what is actually a
sensible in the context of such a show I
don't want to be online for three hours
for that it's so should be within one
hour on that say 90 minutes or something
like that so I'm going to start with the
first game and it's on paper the most
interesting game um but unfortunately
this didn't really materialize it's a
game Wesley so with white against Magnus
cars um we have see form by so remove
that years played earlier in the event
with some success he beat giri in the
first round um and after that he only
played Ross it's quite funny souls
result is always solidly yak near the
lead but never never winning a game
after the first round okay Carlton is
playing the symmetrical and goes for e 6
this is usually an invitation to the
so-called Hedgehog set up here why it's
most promising move sg3 and after be six
the Hedgehog is just around the corner
the Hedgehog arises after whites main
move deform yeah d for ticks Queen takes
d6 this is how black usually play as a
group t1 a 6 and so on we have this
typical formation on the six rank which
is the Hedgehog and so it's playing
something different he plays the minus
p1 um here black still can go for an air
shock setup but it's a bit different he
can go this six here for example you
form a 6d four cakes Teague's and green
to c7 something like that the difference
is that in this position why displayed
rookie 180 form and he was able to take
on d4 with the night without allowing
the bishop trades after the Queen after
deform that what i showed earlier this
here the night recapture is very lame
because black is happy to yeah bring the
Queen around and trade pieces and this
is the idea of rookie one white wants to
play efore d4 and avoid piece trades yes
asics is mostly played to cover b5
that's true um yeah rookie one black
often plays a six or d6 now but you can
also play d5 just play classically in
the sand and this is what cards and does
yawn see txt five now and night xt5
taking with the pawn it's not a great
idea as after d4 we get a position that
looks like some kind of tirage defense
Queens gambit arash um where this is not
very well placed and the pawns are
mostly week so 95 that also keeps this
diagonal open make some sense yeah here
so played the movie form of course white
can also play d4 but after a possible
capture black gains additional
possibility to put a bishop here and
this is often quite interesting adjust a
blocking piece so that
wyd cannot get the full center so what
he did is he played efore immediately
and now if black would take on c3 let's
say black castles and d4 then white will
have a very decent food center this is
an line and position type that for
example vladimir kramnik has played very
successfully in the past however it
seems that the move night before as
played by Carlton is better it seems to
be this just a better move because now
black intends to jump into d3 and that
would obstruct white far too much so g4
is the only move black takes 90 x and
now he plays Knight a to c 6 challenging
this knight on d4 yeah and this is
actually very ok for black yeah and
right now to 166 of course this also
Bishop e3 but this is also not varying
black so much as with trades and he can
easily reduce the pressure going for
knight c6 next and then the position
looks very it's not symmetrical that's
wrong but the C&D file are open and
there is no special reason to believe
widest widest better and that's a
question what about 'if I've in what
particular position
yep trying to answer the question um II
five when instead of taking here you
five um yeah black I don't like a me
take this if we if we look at this kind
of position black tonight's look very
active let's say look b8 and I actually
sorry if you actually get the fork
indirectly the fork is impossible
impossible to prevent unmoving Levin
knife is not possible here yeah i think
i think i covered the line that you
mentioned um yeah I think white taking
this may quite some sense here and now
black takes the Queen and recaptures
with the bishop this is actually
important taking with the night looks
more normal but after night to be five
this is actually quite annoying for Mac
there's this threat here sometimes on d6
and black has a hard time to get rid of
that night if he for example covers the
b7 bishop then why just develops and
it's not quite clear what black is
supposed to do so something like a six
check it's just losing stuff he has to
take with the bishop and now rupee one
was played by so that's a rare move they
normally play Bishop f4 year in this
position but it doesn't seem to lead to
that much either black hose g5 him
attacking the bishop and something like
this can just be answered by taking and
King 287 that whole line looks to be
honest entirely and promising for white
it's very sound hard to lose but also
hard to win
yeah Ruby one bye-bye Wesley is not a
particularly threatening novelty that
same car got raided the rookie I'm
missoula novelty it's just a rambled a 3
and a black jumped into D 3 yeah there
is no big problem here blacks king is ok
on c7 it gets a ruby aidan and now after
those trades Bishop c5 we see that this
position is very very equal yeah that
wasn't a very exciting game and I say
was because it ended after this pendulum
group d three rookie form um yeah Wesley
saw some opening repertoire is very yeah
someone described it it's a bit like a
rock in poker are you yeah you only play
like two aces in position everything
else is kind of not too not too much
risk and this is often very difficult
then to play for window or win games
it's tough sound solid but not very
threatening okay um the next game I
briefly want to check is some kayaking
with white against Giri if you still got
some questions about a games that i have
finished um just them give me justice
pose the question yeah i'm just doing
the Tata Steel games tonight the thing
is with hindsight I shouldn't even have
scheduled this scream as I have to play
an important game tomorrow and still
need to prepare something for that so
yeah anyway we're going for kayaking
Geary and the biggest moment I'm sorry I
need some water the biggest moment of
that game
it's actually happening on move one else
kayaking plays 1b3 quite quite funny one
be three is of course not a bad move at
all but seem very rarely stop and I
don't think I don't think I even have
notes for the game which says a lot
about them about how much how much
interested here anyway one be three
maybe kayaking is also doing that um
because of the candidates tournament
yeah nobody wants to show all their
stuff all that good stuff ok Giri is
going 45 and Bishop to g4 this is a very
decent very decent line I when I was
doing my little serious on on off bid
openings for Wyatt I also covered the
last an opening of course b3 and this
was one of the setups that I felt them
felt doing felt covering but ultimately
I decided to go eat five this is the
more classical way this is not bad
however of course yeah kayaking goes for
g3 yeah double fianchetto and this leads
to some kind of ready set up yeah very
okay for white of course but not very
exciting if white wants to be exciting
against Bishop g4 you can do something
like this f3 is interesting Bishop h5
and now something that night h3 is quite
a creative approach to trying to get the
bishop or you can play the very crazy
movie for tix and Queenie to this is
quite funny and good for winds and blitz
chess as this is the unexpected loss of
a bishop really funny and yeah you can
play this Bishop g4 also against one
before so no problem at all can do that
um ok but kayaking wanted to play sound
solid he played g3 e6 Bishop g2 9f 683
and neither three double fianchetto or
WP on keto this easily could have
happened out of Knight f3 on move one
and then g 3 and so on yeah black is
putting up this set up the yeah similar
to a tory opening and yet developing the
bishop outside of the chain and then
place a triangle this setup is something
that black can almost universally play
against everything that white is playing
which is not efore d4c for ya you can
against not a 3g 3b3 all those stuff can
always play b5 c6 put the bishop out and
so on yeah this is a very simple setup
but also very ok yeah give you it took
about two minutes now against the first
move so wyd now went c4 and this makes
it reti opening the classical way to
reach that would be one night a 3d 5c
for something like something like this
this is the way our position could have
been reached from the classic already
set up on the order
yeah okay so via back into this yeah
it's like a reverse London a 5 a 3 & e 5
yeah this is a way that black definitely
can play it takes the center the same
kind of strategy was played back in the
very first games of the rating systems
by Emanuel Lasker against Reggie himself
in New York I think it was nineteen
twenty four yeah when the red tea
opening was like yeah the the latest
fashion and yeah the absolute newest
that there that there was um ya que aquí
now goes for the capture and placed
reform to get the bishop pair this whole
position is quite unique in that white
has a space disadvantage you don't see
that so much in modern openings but the
idea is that white has good bishops and
they attack black center so it's truly a
some hyper modern kind of opening rookie
8y to took the bishop there and now
played III this is to make sure that the
black pawns don't advance in the center
yeah so quite quite logical q is going
95 to attack those pawns they got
covered and now deform that looks like a
sharp move and it it's it is sharp in
some way it introduces some clock
conflict in the center yeah can played
before him attacking the night trying to
push it back quite quite logical choice
night went back to e6 and now after the
trade he went with a night to see form
it's very important that white
absolutely does not want to take on d4
after black recaptures he always has to
worry about a knight jumping to
for and this is uncomfortable really is
yeah you don't want to give black this
opportunity this is why you place this
and yeah it keeps his options open after
details to capture with the f pawn it
was taken and if I've also taken so a
trade there or be against UConn Bishop
c5 to keep the porn on deform and white
went back yeah the position already has
simplified quite a bit and we see that
here black is preparing the move b5 and
what does not really want to allow that
that the night is pushed around so Queen
B 5 was played and now black went g5 I
think this position is zone is really
roughly equal yeah it's not very own
let's say symmetrical kind of position
but it's very difficult for both sides
to do much black does not want to take
and open White's rookie on their file
and white also does not want to move his
pawn down as it would give away the f4
square or the default square something
like that for example is completely
illogical why activate Black here yeah
white went Bishop t2 year keeping the
tension and black now took yeah for some
concrete play recaptured and rook the
eight yeah and three see that this pawn
is attacked but black is also giving up
on the b7 porn the problem is if white
plays d for now he has this sacrifice
and after pawn takes Knight takes there
are various issues so what he did is he
decided to take on b7 that's a safe
choice and probably the right choice
take stakes Andrew takes the three yeah
and here we have a position that is
completely equal yeah three against
three pawns on one side
the board White has the bishop pair but
the Black Knights have very good safe
outposts and here already they agree to
draw there is not much that both sides
can do here the bishop is attacked and
will probably remove retreat I mean
somewhere here and now maybe Bishop to
perform it's a very equal position I
mean you can continue of course but it's
very hard to imagine one side getting to
something substantial yeah they both
spent time on this it's not like it was
a easy game could be played very young
very quickly but yeah I think draws very
fair result okay um let's look at the
next game that I want to check out this
is really fun against Mickey adams and
i'm just looking at the chat but okay no
no question at the moment yeah we find
had a terrible loss against cars around
before this this game where she
transposed into the king of porn ending
and then blundered it away in one move
and then Adams tournament also was more
stuff so we'd see what those two will
play we've got them Berlin yeah and
we're fine goes for the end game which
is actually showing some desire for a
fight if why just won the draw against
the Bullen you play route d1 and
basically on that level um yeah black is
just not going to win ever so this is
actually a fighting choice ok we get the
end game and I'm not an expert and I
probably won't ever get to that to get
to that state um so I'm not really the
person to tell you a big subtle points
about this I just know what looks kind
of
normal and whatnot um yeah Adams went
for the king eight and age 5 which is
probably the most popular line nowadays
Black is preparing I'm sorry preventing
the g4 move yeah gachinco says who you
fun started well but then a tournament
went downhill yah that's two I already
talked about that in earlier videos I
think that maybe the constant playing
against a super strong opposition is
just a little bit too too much for for
her I mean she's not used of this I'm
used to that opposition round after
round after round and it probably that's
the point where you simply don't have
enough stamina to do it um I mean I just
imagine what what I would do if I'm in
the tournament she's playing against
people that are on average like 100
points higher and this would be like me
playing against grandmasters they are
like 13 days consecutively be very very
tough um okay so Bishop to e7 here by
black 92 the night is quite often
regrouped in this in this line going to
a for looking at this porn things like
that black now ghost Knight age 44 that
trade and now put the bishop back yet to
be honest um and I have to say really
i'm not an expert to me i think a black
already looks quite okay i don't think
that with black i would be um yeah i
would be fearing this position too much
or being diverted too much yeah she went
a 4 here and now adams takes this
opportunity to play g5 gaining space on
the Kings side how many points I would
score in this field you mean in the
Masters Tournament wow I would be happy
with two to three drawers I think
something like that a couple of drawers
I don't see me win win win a game I
think I would be a
I would have a very hard time in the
challenges yeah I mean if you look at
the challenges tournament there are
people like admin earliest got 2440
which is around my level and he's got
like no points it's just it's just tough
um yeah I think they should invite who
you found more to these events are she
she's doing a good job in general I mean
it shows that she can play on that level
it's not like she's getting getting
killed every game it's really not the
case she could have easily been on a
plus two or three score early on she
actually didn't take all of her chances
okay so g5 here by black gaining space
on the King side and making sure that
with the space gain also that the bishop
will get a decent yeah outlook hear that
Ted Bishop yeah black went to play with
c5 and night bishops is six and this
looks really okay the bishop gets to be
on a good diagonal and it doesn't look
very threatening the white pawns yeah I
can like this they don't really feel
very threatening yeah she advanced those
pawns and black got the King up to his
six yeah around here i was thinking hmm
isn't that actually BIA for white I'm
not sure Black has the two bishops the
bishop on c6 is strong there are
sometimes problems with the King
invading White has to be careful here
but she played a very good move not to
be five attacking that weakness there on
c7 and here black more or less has to
take this and after this capture I think
white shouldn't be in any any danger um
black plate c4 however and after this i
think the tables might turn even a
little bit let's see what happens King
g2
a form and here I think who you found
had a had an opportunity to gain some
advantage but it was very difficult to
see and when I say I think it means that
I looked at this with the computer and I
checked what the engine is saying and it
is a very computer-based this kind of
commentary that you that you get right
after the rounds the issue is she played
this and it looks totally normal however
after rook the eighth you cannot play
the move c3 which you would like to do
and we will see why why this is not
possible um I think the c3 was better
preparing no not this preparing bishop
t4 and then maybe King up and f5 this is
what white would would love to do Black
has some issues there yeah for example
if he goes like the rook to a 8 or move
like that then king of three comes and
if you allow kingi for this will get
critical so something like f5 maybe but
after takes takes like it's losing
material gathered line actually
continues with this this this yeah but
why does better him yeah white is
definitely better um the thing is she
played Bishop deform now Mookie eight
and now see three looks like it
transposes to this kind of setup however
this is not the case she actually played
this move now if C 3 black has an
amazing an amazing sequence of moves he
can actually take on d4 takes a three
takes c3 and wow the sea pawn is
dangerous if wide not place king f3 the
sea point is promoting even yeah like
rook back Bishop takes and see one Queen
that's just a loss
so what is why it's supposed to do the
only way is here to play a fire back
yeah and this line is pretty crazy king
d 5 f 6 we are trying to take yourself
so how is black hand like this takes
rook a group takes f7 and c2 I have my
notes here otherwise I would completely
struggle here roop t7 check king sex
rook c7 and why it is just about
stopping the sea por promotes this this
and yeah in this position I'm like king
of three king and five and black maybe
has some winning chances but it's tough
to say nothing that nothing that white
is probably happy and trying to play if
anybody black is winning so this was the
line c3 and she went bishops III and
after that I think any possible chances
for while advantage over Bishop c5 check
f5 check check and this gets traded yeah
whoo qi 7 and white also could have
taken here but maybe she was a little
bit worried that blacks activity here is
too too dangerous I'm sorry I'm
blundering the bishop this first time
and then it's a draw but it's a draw in
both cases rook c700 g7 they pledged a
couple of mumbles which here check check
check check check they agreed to a draw
after all those all those checks so a
game that was probably a rather correct
draw there were ideas for both sides um
I think that's your three move what's
interesting for who you find but
difficult to do with the very little
time on the clock those lines were not
easy
all to play um the next game or are
there any particular questions about
about this game I don't think it was
yeah super interesting to be perfectly
honest it was building games they yeah
sometimes a little bit little bit stay
on yeah sorry for them drinking breaks
but i need some some water here and
there after talking so long no there are
amino k judit polgár played in super
tournaments when she was active but it
doesn't make any sense soon why invite
the women board number two or three they
would just get completely wiped out in a
super tournament and I mean okay you
could invite my real musa chick she's
like 25 50 or so and she wouldn't score
in that event it just it just like that
it's just just too big of a difference
yeah i mean this is like who your finest
is very solid 2 670 and 120 points is is
a huge difference it really is um so i
don't think that she would do great in
this event you can look at the beat
element the challenges tournament
there's juventud playing the chinese
number two and she's struggling a lot in
that event okay um we found adams was
this game what next let's go vehement
gerroff ok we have a an opening that I
actually know a little bit classical
spanish here and the brave yeah the line
that I want to learn and play
occasionally in the internal mentioned
in blitz chess um
I don't know it well yet to be honest
but I think I'm doing still reasonably
okay in my in my games okay this is the
main continuation and now while you play
some somewhat offbeat line the move see
form um it's not a new it has been even
played by the Fisher yeah back in the
1960s when the brea was just about
getting popular and to be honest that
move has never really caught on they
almost exclusively plane IBD to nowadays
um c form is leading to completely an
unusual structures for the rule no pass
as white place the Knight to c3 and pawn
on c4 this looks exactly like an old
Indian defense by the way yeah an old
Indian against Wandy form where the
bishop is just weird on b3 um I think
actually it's hard to imagine that black
should have any problems yes the bishop
is feedback on b3 and the old Indian
wear black garden b5 is not such a
terrible opening anyway of course black
has spent some time learn night to be
eight and so on but white also has moved
his bishop quite a bit okay black played
before attacking that night and night to
you too was played this is of course
involving a porn sec um white can of
course also play Knight a form but this
looks like somewhat offside night that
first for example played in in the game
that actually witnessed life when I was
in Berlin last year in the world rapid
word blitz where kayak were Carlton
played see five year against Malaga
ponds and this night is really misplaced
you know white has to spend some time in
getting it back into the game and I
really don't think that black should
have any problems here yeah night each
whatever was played by over here and now
black can also ignore this thing that is
was hanging but then white has gained
something because he will get in 93
conveniently so snatch the boy yeah what
is why it's idea he goes screen to see
two and a Texas night and in case of
black retreating the piece he has some
kind of compensation yeah for example
let's say 95 white might take this there
are a couple of continuations but taking
ah hi John got jamba following you in
the chat yeah I'm also glad that this is
possible yes streaming why a YouTube is
just much easier yeah Bishop takes and
Luke the one this is probably some
compensation for the for the porn yeah
night 2 3 c5 those moves open up the
position and black is not very very
coordinated cf5 was played this is the
much sharper move um but it turns out
also very okay for black jack white gave
the check d5 and now Bishop e3 just
supporting the center um black does not
have anything great now I feel thought
what about f4 yeah and this is a move it
just leads to completely wacky
complications um white for example can
take this but black plays king edge
eight funnier and thus hanks and now the
Queen Hanks and something like bishop d5
pawn takes Queen takes takes here check
yeah it's just totally bonkers I have no
idea what's going on yeah it's it it's
completely crazy the engine says 000
yeah very very funny I'm protecting the
night with d5 here yeah what can take
this is the issue
yeah this is losing a four-piece I have
five it's okay it's really ok what you
did yeah and here maybe m-f voice is a
bit much even though it's interesting
it's interesting white can take this for
example and blank tapes is here it's a
whole mess it says come complete mess
yeah but ok King edge eight was played I
think this is the more and more solid
decision yeah getting getting out of the
diagonal and making sure that nothing
bad happens there yeah night take see
five now white got the porn back yeah
and this position is quite interesting
yeah Black has this nice looking night
that however doesn't have that many
squares White has chances to go to
deform that can be interesting um it has
this pawn on e5 it's a it's a sharp
interesting position whatever the way it
turned out after Bishop h4 it was a
little bit difficult for wide to make
any progress he definitely wants to get
rid of that night so we place the rook
to have one to prepare three yeah a five
supporting this porn maybe allow this on
the right moment yeah and now i have
three was played hmm yeah black now
basically has to play 93 I'm going back
here is looking somewhat wrong I mean it
seems playable but it's um yeah white
can maybe just take him play a 494 feel
it says he likes my new haircut it's the
same that I have for one and a half
years now so it's a it's not so new just
my picture on YouTube is old yeah so
takes takes on g3 and f4 yeah and this
is a
kind of position where it's rather
difficult to make any headway the reason
is that if you only have bishops in such
a rather close position it is almost
always a little bit static yeah white
basically has just one plan available
this is to push g-form and if black
plays like this Bishop to e6 and maybe
if necessary a queen to d7 my doesn't
even do that but if you imagine this
black is wrong let's draw that again
black is looking at this square so often
that white will not get in to play G
form and if you cannot play G form there
is no way forward you can try some a3
maybe but you need the gal you need the
pieces on the queenside then or not yeah
as they are positioned here with rook on
f3 + f1 they are continued for a bit and
white made this funny King walk yeah
king over to see one and now you were
expecting that may be why does trying to
regroup and try to get in g4 but it
never materialized yeah it did never
materialized rook to g8 and here why he
is playing age form which is the same
thing as a draw offer and he offered a
job as black can just play age 5 and the
game effectively NCM yeah this is um
this is just not very ambitious yeah I
think white um should maybe try to shoot
for some g form but it is difficult to
do it's really difficult to do yeah you
would have to get your roots somewhere
here rg2 hg2 ng1 bishop may be back here
and then g4 but i mean i think that
might should have tried that
um there's little risk I think yeah i
saw that aren't lost in gibraltar
against 2,500 GM yeah i don't think that
black C and D porn can be attacked as
someone is suggesting he addendum or in
the in the chat um how would you do that
you have to attack the sea point but you
can only attack it once you can try for
some a three but it doesn't look like
this is leading to much yeah black bow
just cover that pawn it seems like a
rather equal ish game or the older women
yeah are there any questions on on that
game which wasn't a real thriller I have
to say but this is not one of the more
exciting rounds anyway we have to be
have to be perfectly honest there yeah
rook t1 that's not threatening much 22 a
six-year blackheads rookie a door rook
c8 to cover that it's the only way
forward is to open up some kind of fire
and you can try a three with white at
some point but you also open up your
king that way and like it's not forced
to take he can play that would be eight
and try to take on before hmm well
someone says they like how I play the
modern benoni with black in my blitz
games so I don't do that often and i
usually don't feel I'm doing it well
yeah expectations for the last round I
think I'm I'll talk about that um I talk
about that at the end of the video um
yeah that's why he's rise stopped
already um well he just didn't have a
good event in Qatar but I think he's
doing very well in this tournament is on
fifty percent which is a great result
for him
so that's so define well what do you
expect that he crushes all these guys I
mean he still has huge problems and in
some strategic positions and look at
this look at this match against Peter
Svidler yeah in the in the World Cup
sweetly I was totally killing him if you
would have had better finishing
qualities that match would have been
over very very quickly actually okay so
let's continue what to do we go for
navara Tomashevsky yeah there was some
more exciting games but it's a I covered
them cover them after that um yeah we
had a green sinyun in this game and
Navarro place this line with the printer
a form yeah this is a very safe line
against the Queen's in Ian White has a
couple of sharper options but I think at
this stage of the tournament and you
have to see that it's a very long event
it's a it's a 12 the 12-round some more
conservative options are I think welcome
off okay bishop p.m. and c5 wide takes
on c5 and black takes with the pawn you
can also take with the bishop in this
position but this is some believe to be
slightly better for wider he goes with
castles 93 rook to e1 and so on yeah the
Queen's engine is a very solid opening
someone asks about this it's very much
playable rather flexible for black then
I took with the beep on this is the more
respectable choice nowadays castles 7575
is not seen in this position but yeah I
think it's probably not that great
because black can take and win this porn
and this is not such a big issue quite
often you can sacrifice this pawn but
after Knight c3 and black goes back
White has to go back to c 2 and this is
basically a position that white can
reach with a tempo up because there is
this line and here it's white smooth and
in your suggestion here it's blacksmith
the quits engine is not dry per se as
someone suggested sit just sound and
solid it's a based on solid values and
there are some lines that are drawn but
not more than Queens gambit sore some
other some other lines it depends on the
level on which you're playing if you
play on the super highest level even the
sharpest sharpest lines are considered
raw edge because they they know them so
well and quite often it's just
reproducing some computer stuff yeah I'm
glad that you someone says they enjoy
the commentary thanks I'm glad that you
feel it is useful okay we have those
moves there looking I think quite quite
normal so here um Tomashevsky goes for
Queen to be six Bishop f4 here and g6 d6
seems to be somewhat out of fashion yeah
Luke the aide was the normal move for a
long time but gd6 is also quite quite
normal this is a game navara
thomashefsky look to be one night BTW
seven and before so why does getting
something going on the on the beef
valium
um it looks somewhat dangerous but with
some precise moves it seems there isn't
happening that much look fp8 here um if
why it takes then 20 x is totally fine
the rook is now looking at a protected
protected bishop so why does keeping the
tension as is black yeah slowish moves
am waiting moves it's not so easy to
make some kind of progress here I wonder
where my notes are I made some notes on
this game yeah down yeah G for gaining
some space here by Navarro and Quincy
sound and now we actually get to an
interesting position here navara can
play normal dish moves let's say write
create five very interesting idea yeah
with them Queen a five white is offering
a queen trade and at the same time
destroying his own structure to my
ship's keel accepted this invitation and
now we have a position where it looks
like white is almost a porn down in some
way because this is really useless but
he has this pressure here on d6 yeah
Tomashevsky has to cover that basically
and now 95 very funny tactical motif
opening up the bishop here yeah
Tomashevsky took this um alternatives
well you could have taken on g2 but this
line is extremely extremely computer
ich9 txt seven takes takes Bishop takes
yeah the thing is with f5 Black is with
some miracle move getting this
into the game and the whole situation
after group b 7 is totally unclear very
tough to say what's going on yeah we
have a material wise wide as a pawn down
which is quite active a very strange
position um yeah this is the more
logical continuation I guess Tomashevsky
after Bishop takes gives up an exchange
yeah very interesting way of playing the
VAR i had to take and now went into b7
with this rook and we now have something
very critical Bishop d8 it was attacked
and now a five is hanging 94 and Bishop
to c7 he covers that porn there the next
move here um by navara is probably not
that great play some rock c1 and after
that he probably doesn't have anything
yeah after that there's nothing
happening again any more in terms of an
advantage he maybe could have played
something like this what the computer
suggested keeping the rukon the one for
a moment the problem with his line is
the following after Knight takes you now
hmm cannot put the route back if you
retreat and keep the exchange then black
has to move see form and this is very
much a problem the night is covering
this and like it's not ready for d5 and
if you look at something like this let's
say maybe I maybe even hear something
like this here only black can be better
yeah it's a very murky position but only
black can be better those pawns are very
strong on the night is strong so he felt
yes to avoid that and you can only do
that by taking here
and here you get all your stuff back and
the result is as it is so often total
equality and the draw yeah so there were
some interesting moments in this game
but ultimately a drawing 32 moves there
was a question about the current leader
of the challenges group audubon yeah
he's a very interesting play and paying
very sharp stuff very optimistic kind of
aggressive player will be interesting to
see it's hard to say how those people
fear in the fair in the in the top group
but I think the system is very nice that
they have this challenges tournament
where people can qualify for them for
the for the top group even even to two
places would be cool not just one but
two why not now that's a very
interesting concept and you get new
players to to play there then all the
time I better think em it's not decided
yet even Dre f can still win it and even
sounds wrong Dre F is a very strong
player it's not it's not playing he has
not played in such a super top level
event for a long time okay we only have
two games left and i'm shooting for the
ding vs alien off now and here we got a
Queen's Indian again the Queen zillion
um is played quite a bit now here in
this round and in this tournament in
general
let's see what happens here yeah g3
alien office going from this line the
bishop before check line not very
popular but not a bad line i played this
myself a little bit long time ago but um
i played it a little bit um so Bishop t2
Bishop e7 93 they should be seven I one
looking quite normal the move c6 is
interesting what black is doing is he
prepares to move d5 he can play d5
immediately but quite often players want
to be ready after C takes to capture
with the C porn so this is why he plays
his six first castles instead we form as
possible of course and then like g5 and
yeah now a couple of things are possible
takes takes 95 for example let has been
played in the World Championship match
between anand and carlsen um there's
also this continuation I think this this
this in the 90 form a couple of
interesting continuation inca
continuations um ding is going for
castles this is something that he had
played before in a game against Lazaro
bruising um only last year and we see
how this game went because we follow
this game a bit yeah White has
centralized his rooks and in that
mansion game against bruise on here
played Bishop g5 but now he goes for
Roxy one rook c8 and now an interesting
by doing very surprising move I think he
played the move um knight to e 1 um a
decentralizing move the night goes back
um I'm quite surprised to be honest um
because the night does not not look
there
dangerous there um early enough now
decided to capture on c4 and I somehow
don't like that move um I don't like it
because after that on the night i think
gains a little bit more sense let's say
only one let's see in the game how the
night makes sense um they're all so
what's the move c5 and this looked very
logical to me because the night has left
is post from a three and now black is
attacking this pawn the very logical
continuation now is actually see txt
file and black now takes on d4 that's
interesting right the night is attacked
yeah and now if white wants to do
something he has to play d6 a pause the
moment because it really looks weird but
it does make perfect sense if why it
takes here for example then 95 is good
for black that neither saying okay 86 um
black takes it takes and now night c5
very important move looking at Bishop
and Queen Queen goes up Knight takes
Queen takes and here I think after
something like that saying I'm not sure
that's the best move let's say we should
be several here um I don't think that
black should have any problems why it is
a little bit better and centralized here
with rook sonsie 181 but it does not
look like a position where black should
be in any danger so c5 is a possible
improvement and I am of to concieve form
and played the move b5 and I have some
conceptual problem with this because I
think that now the night is actually
well placed there only one because it
can jump to d3
and on d3 the night makes perfect sense
looking at all those vital squares where
black might initiate a breakthrough this
happened Bishop g5 black played h6 and
takes and takes III and now see the
night might come to d3 and eventually
jump to c5 and everything makes perfect
sense now I really wonder if that was
some the right idea yeah someone says b5
look strange um yeah you know if you
take on c4 how do you free your position
if you give wide enough time you will
play you for you and gain a big Center
you have to to do something yeah I don't
know I don't know I don't think that
this is so bad but it it demands very
precise play the defining set up between
a hedgehog and the Queen's Indian yes
David assault occurs answering that
actually in the chat the Hedgehog always
has the trade of CND porn like in the
Sicilian you have CND pond trader this
is the same in the hedgehog in the
Queen's Indian you have a more fluid
flexible pawn pawn structure in the
center you don't have CND file open all
the time so we had this and now c5 I
think if black now plays the move Bishop
to a 6 then he is still kind of okay
yeah I'm not in love with this position
but it is kind of okay the idea is to
push c5 you covering b5 and yeah white
maybe goes here Bishop f1 so that after
c5 you can actually take here but black
does not have to place you five it can
also go for Knight to d7 preparing this
and maybe after a possible note III then
go from OC five black still has chances
to equalize
and if everything goes all right for him
yeah here for example after takes um
digs digs takes a for black ass rupee
eight and it's so kind of okay here for
example after pawn takes Bishop takes
Knight takes you trade and go a6 and now
you get you to the pin you get denied
back black i think was still not
hopelessly bad yet it just said he has
to be very careful if you place some
some second-rate stuff just a little bit
second-rate it's a lie group the eight
or so then after 93 you have huge
problems look how well the night is
placed it looks at this and especially
at this and if if black is making any
more moves like this let's say that's 94
and now you get to see five something
like that is the total nightmare that
black has to avoid yeah like this and
the sea porn is the worst ever this is
why I didn't like this kind of setup so
much then all of a sudden the night you
want to move made perfect sense what I
enough is doing now however is some bit
tough to understand I mean this is a
very friendly way of putting it i just
don't get the most to be honest um plate
c5 and i understand he was fed up with
being passive but this is a full porn
and you don't get any compensation I
mean absolutely nothing yep it's just a
full porn and on that level no yeah ding
converted this rather rather comfortably
just playing normals centralizing
and harmonizing the position night a
four it's better than taking that's
important if you take then I think
blacks defense is easing somewhat yeah
I'm just keeping this on the board and
then later go into c6 is probably easier
yeah maybe eleonora just miscounted
something and this c5 but it didn't look
good and here white again it's just a
pawn and white has active pieces so
there is absolutely no compensation yeah
the night is no entering here after 96
already alien of resigned he's faced
with this threat and with 90 a check
yeah yeah I think he probably sm
Johannes voluma is suggesting he didn't
have an appealing alternative that's
possible maybe you just said okay my
position sucks what to do yeah and so on
he's decided to break out even though it
wasn't a sound decision yeah um ok so
the final game to check is kiwana van
really and this is the kind of game
where you know beforehand that it will
get interesting I mean you never can be
completely sure but the likelihood is
quite high because karana is in most
cases playing one year for and when
vilius the kind of person who really
sticks to his guns and his guns there
this is an idol so I have to have to I
need my notes they're badly look at that
hey here it is um yep so we got the
night off and
yeah appear what kofsky is giving some
info on the opening and I have to agree
them yeah we got the night off koala is
going F 3 here um I'm not quite sure
this move was not played that often um
it's usually played if you want to go
for the English attack with Bishop b3
but if you want to avoid them Nigel for
line which friend really is not playing
anyway so quite surprising that current
one I went here ultimately that is this
doesn't matter because when really is
playing as e 6th up anyway yeah so he's
playing a line against the English
attack here that has been popular um
yeah for a long time and his head it's
its heyday was in the early 2000s like
round two thousand 1999 and so on
there's some info in the chat yes mm-hmm
I think you're right he went will yet
even played this against them against
his power off back in the day um g-form
h6 castles Bishop e7 h4 are looking
rather rather normal at same before 9a
for Queen a5 and b3 this has been seen a
lot really over the years and now we
come to the first critical position when
vida here is playing or played the move
Bishop to e7 and this seems to be not
that great yeah has already set in the
chat by mr. wood kofsky and they're more
tested line is ninety-five in this
position which has been played in a
number of top-level games for example i
found a game between Nakamura and mvl
from a couple of years ago it normally
continues with a three-year a very shy
kind of position for example on a three
night takes take CM between 67 and white
eggs on a four very sharp stuff one
alternatively um black can try after 95
III think that's also sometimes the rook
c8 move what is given here rook c8 a
takes can I takes Knight takes Queen
takes yeah this is also interesting yeah
it's also interesting for black he
played the move Bishop e7 however and
this seems to be just an inferior
version of of those lines kawana went
for bouquets free after long thought he
definitely had to yeah remember what he
looked at some time ago or was working
out things over the board yes you can
also take Quinn takes before I yes so um
what Marcus saying the in the chat is a
three roots e8 Queen takes yeah sure
that looks possible takes takes Knight
takes pawn takes d5 something like that
yeah and not am absolutely am I cannot
give give out any yeah it's a don't try
this at home kind of line and my advice
is useless but I would lose here with
their with both colors okay let's have a
look at the game a little bit 95 a 3
this is very similar yeah but the
tactics differ a little bit been very
played rook c8 and ATX bean hours flight
now so after night x check Knight takes
Queen
King be too we reach a similar position
to what we have seen earlier but after
d5 the move on Bishop c5 proved to be
rather strong if black instead play
something else I looked at 97 year for
example then rook a one Queen c6 Bishop
g4 is also good for White Knight a5 is
coming let's say e 595 Quincy 7 and
bishops III then white seems to be
better it's still working but why it
should be better yeah he tried this
logically I'm opening up the bishop and
Bishop c5 yeah you're right I'm but
we'll true p be pure I think would cost
you saying you get a position in tempo
down this is essentially the case now
white um now is in excellent shape I
mean really played 27 if you take on
your phone this is the alternative you
can check wide won't capture here and go
now at c5 and this is very dangerous of
the Aslam Queen back and g5 one reason
of that rook h3 move is that you can go
g5 now easily yeah after um takes takes
this rook now is mmm that was wrong this
is protected him so there's not a rope
hanging on h1 the tempo for Wyatt is
super useful um yeah here for example
white is just winning yeah you cannot
move the night even you can try them
let's say you try takes takes and takes
and where are you going with this if you
go back here yeah this is winning the
house
blacks position is really bad and yeah
he tried to bring the Queen back to this
hour but now g5 happened and why the
tech is yeah why the tech is enormous I
didn't watch the official scream no I
didn't watch it I didn't have time i was
teaching the whole day I didn't do do
much in terms of watching um yeah g5
okay Angie five white Sutekh is very
strong he's gotten ng5 and the big
issues also he doesn't have he doesn't
have any direct counter play when really
took traded here and now night to age
seven what else um yeah here um the move
g6 was already um rather strong it was a
good alternative the ideas after g6 if
black takes we can take on d5 bishop has
to take and then the move c4 is rather
strong bishop c6 Queenie one adhere
black can actually resign immediately as
e6 is collapsing that move was very
strong alternative g6 but f-for what
kawana plate is also making lots of
sense of course we shouldn't forget that
this is pretty rotten ear the nylon 87
while All Whites pieces are super active
black plate Queen to see seven tre it
and night up to c5 hmm like it's in in
really bad shape he tried a fire this is
the I think relatively the best chance
now the move Bishop g2 was strong for
koala the idea said after pawn takes you
take take and take here again this is
not playing you're threatened e6
but what he played was also not bad g6
it's may be objectively a little bit
less um less precise but why it is still
a lot better the idea was to go for this
and this is threatening threatening a
lot yeah especially f5 to f6 check is
poor yeah it's a big issue here the best
move of invading was Queen to c7 even
though it's very unlikely that this
would have saved and white still can
play up six Chan and King back and some
rookie one for example that doesn't look
good but it's tougher than the game in
the game he played groups before and now
f6 was even a bit stronger as now after
King back white can actually take and
take and now the position opens up
decisively check black can do this but
it doesn't really help now we are
threatening Queen g five years wide and
check something like this is winning the
Queen yeah check this is basically now
the end of the game the king wok did
walk up here and now the Jeep one is
promoting Queen back and Queenie 5j b5
while that's a nightmare I didn't even
check the rest of this game so ok he
actually gave a wide the opportunity to
promote yeah he could have taken yeah
but after King's you want it's it's game
over you can check you like comic art
salam orbits White has just too much too
much material so that was a waitin for
kawana in this crucial game against when
really what is the consequence for the
tournament standing um before the final
round counsel is leading the event
with a very nice score of plus 5 15
games lost no game at all um a half
point behind that we've got kawana so
Caruana has chances to catch up two
cards or even overtake him in case of
her cousin loss Carlton is playing ding
Liren who's after the wind today is on
play on the third place he's one point
behind Carlton so if ding wins he would
equalize or would get to the same score
skousen is and what type with a bottom
yeah get him get a tie with cards so
there are many different possibilities
I'm not quite sure to be honest about
koalas pairing in the final round let me
let me check quickly who is playing I
really like to know that kawana is
playing black against Tomashevsky hmm
that's difficult yeah so my bed for the
final standing of that tournament I can
give you a clear clear gasps um I'm not
about I don't think they have they don't
have tire in terms of playoffs or
anything like that and I don't think we
get one my prediction is that both those
crucial games will end in drawers yeah I
don't think that kawana can beat
Tomashevsky with black would be very
difficult to do to do that um
Tomashevsky will be happy with the draw
difficult and i think carlton has called
white against ding and if cars and does
not want to lose with white he won't so
my prediction is Carlton ding Liren draw
too much chefs ki can wanna draw so it
will be an outright win for cards and I
think a pretty deserved one
and if i'm not mistaken thousand wasn't
in trouble in any of the games at least
not something something there was a
terrible trouble let's say um so I think
this is what what will most likely
happen if you watch the tournament or if
you tend to watch the tournament live
tomorrow take into account that they
start earlier yeah they start at noon
central european time so if you want to
watch make sure to tune in at the right
time um I cannot watch myself and
playing a game on my own um tomorrow
playing in the second German leak I will
face a good grandmas I don't know who I
will face but can be up to 2,600 so keep
fingers crossed for that I will be
starting my prep in a couple of minutes
minutes yeah I mean it's difficult to
prepare anyway because I don't know who
I'm exactly playing it can be two or
three different different guys and yeah
okay i hope you undergo enjoyed the
coverage of this round 12 so am i think
i will probably come around 13 the same
as I did this if you enjoyed it i will
definitely do that but it's something
that i have read this would be tomorrow
evening yeah and i'm not sure that i can
do that easily because i have played
this tournament game tomorrow so it will
see how fit and my moods are let's say
after that maybe we get a video on that
he came it depends on how it how it goes
I didn't have any league games recently
that I felt were worth covering okay i
hope you enjoyed it i'll be off for
tonight and i think i'll probably be on
tomorrow with either a live stream or a
regular video thanks a lot for watching
bye bye
you